comment
[Musique]
le bloc africain est aujourd'hui le plus
beau prolongement de la métropole
prendrait actualité vous présente
quelques aspects de la west une des plus
grandes réalisations coloniale qui ait
jamais été entreprise dans le monde et
l'aménagement des immenses territoires
terrils au nord du niger pr 1500 hommes
ont travaillé ici pendant quatre années
[Musique]
le niger prend sa source au voisinage de
l'océan il s'en éloigne remonte vers le
nord aux confins du sahara pour
redescendre ensuite vers le sud et se
jeter dans l'atlantique tout fait penser
qu autrefois il terminait sa course dans
un vaste lac centrale le niger ayant au
cours des siècles surélevé son lit et
trouver son cours actuel
le nak disparu en laissant subsister
d'important d'influent qui ça c'est cher
à leur tour il apparut ainsi qu il
suffirait d levé légèrement le niveau du
fleuve à l'aide d'un barrage pour
renaître en hausse et d'effluents c'est
cette idée qui fut à l'origine de
l'oeuvre magnifique réalisé dans cette
région jusque là si abandonné par
l'office du niger les eaux ainsi retenus
sont dirigés par un grand canal
adducteur sur deux années plus principal
de ces vannes loïra rejoindre les
anciens d'effluents du niger qui les
conduiront à plus de 150 km au nord est
de 100 km à l'est les surfaces
irrigables sont plus vastes que la corse
la brousse a fait place à d'immenses
culture le soleil se réfléchit sur l'eau
qui les beignes uniformément tout un
système de vannes permet de régler le
débit dans les canaux par cutter et dans
les arts oseurs en fonction des besoins
de l'irrigation l'innombrable rigole
permettent de beignets chaque pied de
coton chaque pouce de terrain
l'objectif de ce projet était de
satisfaire les besoins en coton le lin
de ses textures française est d'assurer
la sécurité alimentaire des régions
sahéliennes de l' empire français
d'afrique de l'ouest
et cultivent le riz de ses enfants
telle est la france d'outre-mer dont les
hommes
ce n'est qu'un commencement le travail
continue chaque jour la brusque recul
davantage dans un proche avenir
cinq cent mille hectares devront être
cultivé concrétisant ainsi la réussite
d'une grande oeuvre français je ne
pouvais ne pas une hauteur en termes de
potentiel irrigable nous avons avoir un
point d'écart on peut y lire
et aujourd'hui le mali depuis 1903 demi
centimètre de 160 jusqu'à maintenant on
n'a pas pu dépasser le cap des 5000
hectares vous voyez comme quoi rien à
faire je pense que l'office du niger
ces joyaux pour le monde est le fils du
niger
si à notre roi dans le monde il n'y en a
pas tête 1 million d'hectares où nouveau
signé par gravité on peut faire toutes
les cultures toutes lettres étudie les
cultures industrielles la gauche du sud
européen salue tous ce que nous devons
faire à l'avenir de gm je pense que
l'enjeu est connu mais les dix plages et
primes du mali je suis convaincu que
c'est indiscutable ça le refus du niger
dans la mesure où l'exploitation des
sols apparaîtra comme l'un des enjeux
futurs de la paix et de la stabilité
dans les états dans le sillage d'une
économie libéralisée en crise et d'une
crise financière dans les pentes
l'afrique n'a que cette ère pour s'en
sortir
[Applaudissements]
à falloir trouver senna qu'elle coure à
l'uni mène à flot et la flore marais de
route il a vu que bolt sera anyama
iannetta dorothée bis et n'a qu'à la
radio
arakawa que l'arrêt du lié à
l'indépendance en 1960 les terres de
l'office du niger reviennent à l'état
malien qui les attribue aux agriculteurs
locaux sous condition du paiement d'une
redevance pour l'irrigation intérêts
agricoles de la zone a entraîné de
nombreux agriculteurs à s'installer
aujourd'hui nous sommes 70 à vivre la
terre soit parce que 90% de la
population ici activités agricoles et
wii et à la riziculture l'évolution
économique nous soumet à une précarité
de plus en plus présente et la gestion
politique doit éloigner de nos
préoccupations n'arrive pas à endiguer
ce phénomène
nous sommes de plus en plus fragile les
paysans comme marc et moi devons faire
face aux difficultés
oman a connu d'aménagement de la zone et
le développement d'un réseau culture
[Applaudissements]
après la récolte faux d'une production
insuffisante et des familles arrivent à
conserver de semences d'une saison à
l'autre
nous sommes donc contraints d'acheter de
nouvelles chaque année
j'ai gagné
ouais
en 1960 des petites parcelles de 1 à 6
ha nous ont été attribués en fonction du
nombre de personnes à chaque frag
aujourd'hui à cause de la
surexploitation des terres
s'appauvrissent d'année en année elle un
rendement très faible au maximum trois
tonnes par hectare c'est qu'elle est
largement insuffisant pour nous fans qui
se sont beaucoup à brad
[Applaudissements]
le père racaille avait là bas
ada de l'impossible
à la folie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà
[Applaudissements]
paraît
à suivre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pokora le canada anglais n'est qu'à 12
académies de la foulée wafi ma couenne
fin 2007 afin de revaloriser le secteur
agricole est de stimuler la production
de riz l'état malien lance le programme
initiative riz fanga l'état pourra
flâner camadini forme papier bible à
l'initiative riz c'est une volonté du
gouvernement d'encourager beaucoup plus
la production que les importations
il ya eu des effets bénéfiques mais en
même temps d'initiative de l'est a
permis de révéler des insuffisances qui
existe dans le système n'était d'ivry
koné cana et affirmé qu à vous intégrer
la mouse avec m mais on nous y ait du
talent et audace à voir avec de
l'engrais qui a été acheté par le
gouvernement à l'époque nous ici nous
avons à l'office du niger c'est le
cerveau qui avait initié une commission
d'approvisionnement et un appel d'offres
l'office nous appuie avec notre conseil
qui était l'ancien hugo maintenant on
fait l'appel d'offres et on avait fait
l'appel d'offres on avait l'engrais a un
prix mais à notre grande surprise on a
dit que le gouvernement est à chaque
partie acheter la nouvelle
dix mille fois plus cher au pays que non
nous avons eu c'est ce n'est pas
compréhensible que dans la seule zone de
l'office du niger nous ne puissions
avoir un prix aussi bas et que dans tout
sur toute l'étendue du pays on achète de
l'engrais donc le stock nouveau
le plus élevé et qu'on achète plus cher
naturellement les combats maintenant nos
bras
gc ca
avant pourquoi avoir fait du mal à me
vendre
nous sommes au mois de juin et la
récolte ne s'annonce que fin octobre
déjà chez omar comme chez la plupart
d'entre nous on ne vit que du mil du
maïs et de riz importé de chine
n'est-il pas incroyable d'acheter du riz
qui a parcouru des milliers de
kilomètres
deux fois moins chers que le poulet se
place
[Musique]
donilon
m
hamel
mado mam un nouveau nom
[Musique]
depuis une quinzaine d'années nous
pratiquons la contre saison c'est à dire
une deuxième ryjkov dans l'année il
s'agit d'une variété de riz de cyclique
au cette pratique apories le sol
néamoins et si nous pensons que rien
n'est plus rentable que le camp de césar
ces années al hayya année d'arts à
balocco la tournée samia ta nea sera à
marignane à tous habitent à ifrane et
engraissement du foie rate of heroes que
les oies nimaga climat l'avocat guy
baratte les bases arrières à gala alors
que nous cherchons des solutions à nos
problèmes nous voisins exploitants
déterrement aménagé de l'office ont
confronté à bien d'autres difficultés du
gouvernement malien pense que le
développement de la zone dépend des
hommes de l'agro business mondial
elle ainsi et favorise l'installation
des investisseurs nationaux et
internationaux sur ses terres
[Applaudissements]
nous avons des relations nous avons de
l'eau nous avons les hommes qu'on arrive
à nous et le mali est même allé prendre
nos ambitions à l'origine de la filière
c'est pourquoi à un moment donné l'état
malien a estimé que c'était même
légitime que il faut ouvrir le sud du
niger non seulement les inverseurs
machenaud aussi bien qu'étranger c'est
dans ce contexte que nous avons
enregistré de l'arrivée d'un certain
nombre
deux partenaires techniques notamment
est
les chinois et qui était l'un des pays
acp en 1260 qui ont voulu agrandir le
potentiel de la culture de la canne à
qui on est en train d'étudier un blanc
vert militaire pour créer une sucrerie
il ya une question de spéculations les
chinois ils ont plus de 1000 hectares il
ya plus de dix ans ils sont installés là
mais pour le moment ils n'exploitent
pratiquement et bien c'est un film
l'exploitation qui sont en train de
faire sur l'e mail est il paie environ
dix mille francs je crois que c'est dans
les environs du 10 mille francs de
redevances par un et il nous à ces gens
à des manières à 120 mille francs je
trouve quelque part qu'il ya une
aberration et c'était qu'ils occupent
aujourd'hui il est nous à qui à ceux là
qui étaient là avant même que les gens
se lancer ce message qui avait il
existait des hommes qui avaient une
autre couleur de l'année
nous avons également le groupement
shafer un groupement sud africain avec
un processeur de berre de fond et
qu'elle à pourvoir cuillé la deuxième
super de markala qui vont aussi aménagé
environ 15000 un des chefs militaires
ensuite nous avons aussi à côté du mois
un qui va aménager pour le contrat sous
région pour les crs qui répond à la
vocation sous régionale de la fugue du
niger aménagé au moins 11 mai le cac 40
est affecté
mais dans un premier temps ivoire
ménages est de 1500 480 ha
quand de 2000 hectares obligatoirement
sites ont été mis les cartouches et un
vinyle il faut que j'y aille ménage
avant d'avoir les diffusions de tâches
par visite pour un c'est le producteur
qui est kenza farah mois et alors que
dans toutes les conditions
l'école les centres de santé les
fourrages l'espace pour les jeunes tout
ce qu'il faut
adam la bourse ou ailleurs à la fois
jacqueline maquet et hannibal kadhafi et
de combien de groupes à la nuque m'bala
a dévalé
douaniers de brial c'est sa mère annie
dits under en balahachi dîner mais chez
doudou lomé mais c'est un don juan est
d'ailleurs à sa machine on se l'arraché
amin amin a failli nous entamions 26 ans
bien sûr le malade il ya aussi qui est
là et qui a acquis l état malien sur la
base d'une convention a donné le
principe d'un déménagement de sa
médaille car le projet malibya c'est
encore c'est encore plus dangereux parce
que il ya tout eu il ya toute une
opacité autour de cette acquisition
moi je ne dirais pas acquisitions je
dirai clairement capables
c'est un projet de partenariat sud-sud
la libye est un pays africain
le mali est un pays africain deuxième
partenaire qui a été par contre la libye
a ouvert le premier bien sûr je suis sur
le bourgeois et pour 40 km2 de cadeaux
de canal de 19,1 qui ont été aménagés et
et qui dit ce type ont été aménagés et
qui vont irriguer 300000 étape pour les
petits agriculteurs et les vrd du canada
va déboucher sur des périmètres que la
libye mais met en valeur et il ya des
villages qui sont là et on a fait
quelque chose qu'on a pas fait pendant
qu'on était colonisée on a de fait le
canal il ya certains canaux qui ont été
creusés à la main c'était la
colonisation
mon arrivée à une tempe on a fait dévier
le canal c'est yahia ben ali vous pouvez
voir saâdia ballet tout juste au niveau
du camp militaire d'agban et on a fait
dévier le kama mais ici quand on creuse
et le canal de malibya on est venue
tomber sur des deux cimetières un
cimetière musulman un cimetière chrétien
qu'est ce qu'on a trouvé de mieux à
faire c'est d'aller creuser une grande
tome est devenu d'étirer le cas de la
ville allait les quitter la ouate hymne
à malibu hagner maintenant avec
l'entreprise
on avait demandé à ses collègues a voulu
dire quand même beaucoup pour ses katas
pour ibm pour qu'au moins son sac à dos
un outil donc maintenant villageois gré
ou le cadre aucun cas maintenant ouhlala
beaucoup pour me suis pour ma peau pour
moi c'est l'accord du 18 juin à l'aller
à part la paix la vermine eu comme ça
oui
moi j'ai une grandeur ni bernard cargo
si kto quatre pattes est donc maintenant
aux colonies faut nous coûtera 4 l'été
le rouge bordeaux il est là mounana pour
la cavale à travers c'est toute la
famille qui a tenu à saluer mois de
composer massawa besoin d'un monument de
composer au total
au café au soleil rejoignez koulou fait
taper des fosses communes et lloris
lamotte est doué pour ce couple de fond
à fond à fond avec christian t
ça c'est quand on est dépendant je me
demande quel contenu on donne un autre
mot indépendance et on nous dit qu'il
n'ya pas de problème est que c'est des
agitateurs des gens ce qui soulève des
faux problèmes
c'est bien de rester dans son palais le
dire qu'il n'ya pas de problème s'il y
est de rester dans son bureau dit qu'il
n'y a pas de problème donc nous nous
pensons que nous pourrions libyen est un
projet digne de ce nom et nous
l'encourageons nous pensons que ça peut
être un facteur de développement de
véritables la zone de l'office du niger
à ma mère à doha quot quot ou venant
très bas record d'appels en plus large
en amenant de la terre et le cdh aux
producteurs les petits un gratin de deux
ou à trois etarras 4 hectares et ils ont
su qu'on appelle le canada cotation
annuels
bons débuts furent créés les petits
producteurs qui sera installée et
chantant de passer ces parcelles de fils
un petit fils et petit fils
ils n'ont jamais été inquiétés jamais de
la vie au fusil dreno l'occasion des
nues nirvana sera donc ma mode arguments
l'ère du fonac mal à l'ena cédera
groupement glace sur la nuque maqam
envoyer du courrier
kasmi de nos contrôles à la peau un
galet neyret sera quasiment canal
cabanas callà heure-là monde à aller me
alana mais sûrement et gérard houllier -
johanna mokrani acclamé mois faits a
rappelé me mal est fait au fusil très
académique ou lui qu au loup à mono
jojoy novak est aujourd'hui on fait en
sorte qu m11 papiers établis par la
colonisation annuler tous les droits
qu'ils avaient su de l'acteur sait pas
que c'est déjà ne pas comprendre ça
quand les gens prennent l appareil
nous sommes là depuis des millénaires
nos villes est son millénaire il ya des
vies la cure sur l'adjectif 807 changé
on vient parce qu'il ya carence il ya
environ cinq ans une soixantaine
d'années on a posé un bandage
ces gens n'ont plus aucun doigt leurs
terres ils font partie d'un titre
foncier dont handicap est disposé à tout
le monde ce n'est pas acceptable ce
n'est pas convenable ce n'est pas
possible
à l'évocation du 4 août les wanna make a
officié génie maltais loi mallié ni mal
de under bon terreau est là est née la
mostra qu'à ma barricades mais si vous
voulez toujours dit qu'à marquer 0-1
adamu nigeria à bollène a emmené à kehl
et là on me now when la moue du fouillis
on descend mauvais on dit en effet on me
connaissait
ayo d'eschyle aux neuf autres états
cauet mallié aucun a glissé que je fais
on roule cowboys homophobie à l'ena
soraya ahras les doigts coiffe la
couronne a raflé
pour un agriculteur la terre c'est son
outil si on lui retire sa parcelle et
faut lui donner et notre passé comment
peut-on prétendre soutirer un peuple de
la pauvreté un peu et essentiellement
agricole est bradé ses terres où les
prêter à des pays amis
c'est paradoxal il me semble comment
peut-on combattre la misère la pauvreté
en disant aux pauvres paysans de se
mettre au service de grandes firmes
agricole d'agrobusiness comme simple
ouvrier
comment peut-on par exemple du bouilh et
des hommes de l'achat et leur promettre
le bonheur quand tu retires la terre des
gens c est que comme disait parce qu'ils
ont passés dans certains villages ils
leur ont demandé qu'est ce que nous
allons créer be vous allez travailler
davantage et ces gens s'ils n'ont pas
choisi d'être des ouvriers agricoles
[Musique]
la mosson s'annonce un peu toutes nos
familles c'est juste un petit moment de
bonheur peut le dire la quête de ou tram
[Musique]
oui
on amène un ami
[Musique]
non
ça va
[Musique]
ma faim
[Applaudissements]
dell du captage de la notion de prix
avec les commerçants du village
c'est super nous aider de temps à notre
temps de l'âge
oui
alors
vendre il nous est donc indispensable
mais une fois les d'être embauché
quelques problèmes financiers réseau lee
il nous reste plus grand chose
il nous faut alors faire appel aux
fleurs et aux amis pour la survie de la
famille
[Musique]
bon là mais wang aux médias et au hasard
y avait de l'eau nous
dans ma vie raconte m
on
en bas
[Musique]
à voir les chiffres du rsa
diot fruitiers mardi l'ebita vanek ligne
bravo à mon rôle comme l'hymne à
l'office du niger
traditionnellement c'est un contrat qui
est que nous signons avec l'office du
niger et dans le contrat il est dit
qu'on doit payer une certaine redevance
et cette élégance ne va pas loin ça
laisse à l'office du niger
c'est pour l'entretien des réseaux tct
des réseaux et ensuite c'est pour le
fonctionnement du personnel qui sert à
l'entretien la surveillance de ses
réseaux et la carte été mené est
calculée wata année johnny pour les
classes à la mecque from n'at-il à
wasquehal yves deniaud faisait pas peur
du tout nouveau musée a perdu la roue
attendons donc finalement au drame dans
la partie de la blue lake afro tous
attribuent leurs produits
dyadem la fourmi nominé avec programme
de guerre quoi amener un ouragan sur la
mini key man o'war m'asseoir la barre à
terre donc finalement dos à dos les far
from l'attaquant a passé son fils du
désert la baraque en avoir mon sera
barrée de naissance à de gros sont là
signe de décence avait déjà atterri à
bbva se tenait à la forêt mais mollo
nenê mollo font et morale dit les idées
à quai maintenez un malotru légumes à
l'eau qui nous salit bail à la table
s'anime annaba bois et on va quand même
au nom de la rose nous allions bien qu'à
court colombo honda nissan et banana
divita vie david niven ne résout pas
encore abonné au site
une machine de babeau au physique a dit
à hrw à l'est de la ville a t by iphone
on a le temps du rock on est affamé
local nasa ramalho l'auteur de l'offre
au maroc au banni le problème de
drainage et s'est posée partout dans
tout sur toutes les superficies la
gestion il faut reconnaître aussi je le
dis vous et le faut elle est malsaine
part peut-être dans toutes les zones
ou bien à des degrés à des variantes
différentes en tout cas elle n'est pas
tout à fait clair il ya une étude de
l'office du niger qui avait été
commandité par l'office du niger et
c'est un bureau d'études canadien qui
avait fait l'étude mais elle était
ressortie de cette étude que
pendant deux ans l'entretien n'avait pas
été fait ça ce n'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est l'étude de kilari collaro d'amour
à celui des salariés et les féroé c'est
trois sacrements bon et voilà from là
coin des bourleux outil sous les soins
quoi notre coeu lola sénat
yannick favennec et faut que les
décollages et l'ebit kabbara coco frau
qui légua l'iao fromilhague larigot tony
bloom les tissus sains al sagazly
dialoguer waka flocka tous au boulot de
l'académie roma tient la droitière de
belmont
[Musique]
pour m
le ballon d'or noir à col haut débit ça
va nickel et niga jamal el arabi mais
dhabi gas nadia maintenant les chrétiens
comme un galet nationaux chinamasa
canada l'été
au delà
à la ferme
le développement pour moi c'est comme
une charrette ou bien une charge utile
et par 2 but de labour le sait
l'administration l'autre c'est la
profession agricole
si vous n'allez pas dans le même sens la
charrue bas avant c'est difficilement le
vrai problème c'est un problème
d'organisation et la gestion de notre
exploitation la structuration des
organisations même des poules du
ternaire tout ça ça pose problème
on va continuer à tendre la main à ces
européens alors que nous on a la
possibilité on a toutes les ressources
est ici sous nos pieds si on veut
développer l'office du niger ce n'est
pas dans les discours politiques c'est
le producteur qu'on associe les
producteurs on dire qu'il ya eu la
restructuration et coeur n'a pas ya pas
eu de préparation on pense seulement aux
paysans mais y'a l'encadrement aussi ken
mentalité qui n'a pas bougé d'un iota
cet encadrement n'arrive pas à
comprendre que c'est des analphabètes
depuis se réfléchir avoir une certaine
capacité de réflexion
je me suis dit aujourd'hui que l'office
du niger est un paradis parce que je
veux c'est que il y ait cette
intelligence que les chances accepte
d'être critique et qu'ils acceptent de
se remettre en cause de regarder et
d'aller de l'avant et c'est ce que nous
montre
d'ordinaire on attend dire n'importe
quel petit politiques pensent que la
terre appartient à l'état soit mais
l'état ne peut pas se prévaloir de ce un
simple principe pour les exploiter à des
fins abusives
si la terre appartient à l'état il
faudrait se poser la question de savoir
à qui appartient à l'état et là l'on
verra que l'état appartient aux
populations aux paysans aux halles au
cutter qui sont les plus nombreux en
afrique
[Musique]
oh
un livre la main à nos amis romane
[Musique]
on aime
nombre comme un mot
[Musique]
oh
m
[Musique]
oh
non
[Musique]
obama
voilà du grammy là mon ami et moi même
là
[Musique]
amano
hahaha
on y voit neuner année des médias
[Musique]
vivez la can
oh
[Musique]
ma mère
à
non
année
[Musique]